fou
lorsque j'avais cinq ans et qu'on me
demandait qu'est ce que tu veux faire
quand tu seras grand
je voulais être pompier puis astronautes
puis ventriloque en fait tout était
possible
puis quand j'ai eu 15 ans et qu'on me
demander tu veux faire quoi dans la vie
ben ça faisait plus délicat la fallait
choisir décidé d'une case et puis quand
j'ai eu 25 ans la question était devenu
qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie
et là ça devenait embarrassante
puis l'amusant mon métier c'est
beatboxer alors c'est pas un métier mais
c'est mon métier
tout comme je suis et musiciens
performeurs directeur artistique
chercheurs entrepreneurs
dick et puis tous ces métiers là bas je
les ai appris un peu sur le tas manière
autodidacte j'ai capitalisé tout un tas
de compétences de savoir-faire au
contact des autres
en montant des projets et pour monter
ses projets avec ses collaborateurs tous
ses partenaires tous ses amis en fait on
avait des armes qui étaient le temps
qu'ils étaient nos compétences et la
complémentarité de ses compétences
et puis surtout l'enthousiasmé il se
trouve que avec certains d'entre eux il
ya quelques années on a créé une
compagnie qui s'appelle organique
orchestra avec laquelle on crée des
spectacles les installations
interactives pas mal de d'ateliers de
transmission pédagogique mais aussi des
outils des outils techniques comme ce
gant
qui finalement sur scène me permet
d'enregistrer ma voix de pouvoir la
contrôler en l'espace de contrôle et de
la vidéo la lumière etc
et puis donc a été créé pour un
spectacle et puis il se trouve que en
fait on s'est vite rendu compte que il
pouvait avoir tout un tas d'autres
usages au delà de ces spectacles qui
pouvait servir pour du contrôle
domotique du service handicap jeux vidéo
et finalement à l'intérieur de la
compagnie on a créé de manière
informelle un laboratoire
alors c'est pas un laboratoire
institutionnel il n'est pas
universitaire il n'est pas industriel
mais c'est notre labo un labo créativité
technique et politique est régulièrement
on organise ce qu'on appelle assez
basiquement des workshops dans lesquels
on invite tout un tas de gens alors
c'est des artistes et des geeks
parfois c'est un physicien charpentier
un développeur de jeux vidéo et on
invite tous ces gens à travailler
ensemble et à créer des objets
interactifs
il se trouve que à l'occasion d'un
workshop on a créé des choses comme tout
un tas de choses en papier comme le
carrousel ce carrousel est un carrousel
est en fait c'est un jeu vidéo dont les
décors en papier sont mécanisés et on
joue avec ce petit personnage en
frottant en soufflant sur du papier etc
on a fait des petits avatars des
beatboxers en papier qui répondent à la
voix ou encore les pages d'un bouquin
qui s'appelle idem et quand on les
décroche elles deviennent tactile et
permettent de manipuler tout un tas
d'autres médias bref à l'intérieur de
ceux de ces world cup
et puis au sein du labo surtout ont créé
tout un tas d'outils et en fait on a
décidé avec le temps que ces outils il
appartiendrait à ce qui les fait qui les
font rêver
et puis à ceux qui voudraient les faire
grandir il ya une phrase comme ça une
garde
à l'intérieur du workshop quai de la
matière comme des idées nous ne sommes
que les vecteurs
laissons-le être vertueux en offrant au
monde de s'approprier ce à quoi nous
aurons contribué en fait on aime bien
ici de remettre un peu les remettre en
question un petit peu les modèles qui
sont qui nous sont offerts les ceux avec
lesquels on a grandi souvent que ce soit
ses modèles de propriété ou tout
simplement les méthodes de travail à
l'intérieur des workshops les quelque
chose de très organique en fait chacun
arrive avec ses compétences il ya tout
un tas d'outils on a un laps de temps un
espace et puis on se met à créer sans
objectifs de productivité et c'est super
puissant en fait on crée énormément
d'objets qu'on du sens voire d'utilité
ça me fait penser qu'en fait dans
n'importe quel environnement
ça ça fonctionne l'expérimentation se
laisser la possibilité d'expérimenter
vous comme moi on a des chercheurs que
ce soit dans notre environnement
professionnel dans un environnement
associatif éducationnel institutionnels
on a toujours la possibilité déjà de
s'approprier les connaissances les
objets les idées à l'ère d'internet il
ya énormément de choses qui sont
accessibles de détourner leur usage
premier
des outils et concepts de transmettre
car c'est dans les changes que les idées
deviennent vertueuse et puis surtout dit
terré parce qu'il ya pas de méthode
qu'ils soient inscrits chronologiquement
comme absolue et que c'est en passant
par les différentes couches qu'on trouve
les solutions les plus pertinentes
finalement ce qui me semble pertinent
c'est moins les méthodes que deux ans
faire des boîtes à outils qui nous
rendent actifs interactif
face aux problématiques par exemple dans
l'éducation
on sait tous aujourd'hui qu'à l'ère
d'internet le rôle de l'enseignant et
moins de transmettre la connaissance que
d'apprendre à la choisir
il se trouve que avec des programmes
massifs qui sont sur des territoires
grand comme un pays on se retrouve
forcément dans des méthodes qui
deviennent très inertielle et qui met
souvent une génération avant de devenir
agile or par la multiplicité
d'expérimentation on devient dynamique
on devient interactif trompe
et puis on réussit mais on a beaucoup
plus d'exemples différents pour pouvoir
grandir
par ailleurs le monde du travail dans
lequel on évolue avec chacun nos métiers
est en train de beaucoup changé
finalement ce vieux rêve du plein emploi
est en train de sombrer devant une
énième révolution industrielle qui
passent par internet par les big data
tout un tas de choses comme ça qui font
du travail ben y en a de moins en moins
et finalement des ressources y en a
toujours autant
je rêve d'un monde dans pas si longtemps
dans lequel ce travail et ces ressources
seraient mieux répartis de manière à ce
qu'on est tous plus de temps de temps
pour apprendre de temps pour
expérimenter de temps pour enrichir nos
compétences nos savoir-faire nos
capacités et si vous pose cette question
de qu'est ce que tu veux faire quand tu
seras grand
j'ai envie de dire quelque chose que
j'aime les choses qui me font envie
il ya tout un tas de choses que je
connais pas encore
je serai peut-être navigateur philosophe
et menuisiers et que les opportunités
mon enthousiasme mais collaboration et
ma curiosité
j'espère ne permettront de ne pas avoir
à choisir avant d'être grand
e
hobo beaucoup
oh oh oh oh oh
didier
non
nous
il
on est comme ça
et affronter